bonjour jérémy stealth merci de répondre
à nos questions cet après midi londres
qui sanctionne donc cinq banques on
vient entendre boris johnson ainsi que
trois personnes influentes en russie
quelles conséquences pour l'économie
russe
ça c'est pour les pour les russes à dire
il faut dire que ce c'est en quelque
sorte un premier ensemble de sanctions
et je pense que si le gouvernement
considère que
ce qu'il compense comme est comme étant
une agression contre l'ukraine si ça
continue il y aura d'autres sanctions
donc c'est le un avenir c'est l'envoi
des sanctions du même type d'abord
contre des individus contre des banques
comme vous le savez le graal en quelque
sorte que pour le moment c'est l'idée
d'un d'une sanction qui viserait tout le
système des paiements en est exact le
système swift mais pour que cela
[Musique]
entre en vigueur il faudrait un lot
concours de l'europe ainsi que des états
unis donc on a un premier ensemble de
sanction purement britanniques mais ce
qui est
derrière la tête boris johnson c'est un
ensemble de sanctions beaucoup plus
graves mais qui réunirent est presque
tous les pays occidentaux
mais on vous dit qu'il faudrait
que les états unis et la grande bretagne
à l'europe se mettre d'accord on sait
que les américains et les britanniques
sont souvent plus dur que les français
et les allemands par exemple même si
quand même la seule aujourd'hui suspend
donc l'autorisation de
du gazoduc nord stream 2 est-ce que ce
que vous venez d'évoquer est ce que
c'est possible
c'est concevable se parle tout dépend du
degré de menace perçue par les européens
en même temps boris johnson indique qu'
il laisse la porte ouverte toujours à
une solution diplomatique ce qui est le
cas bien sûr avec les autres nations
européennes et les états unis donc on
n'est pas encore dans la pire des
situations
il y a encore du temps pour une forme de
résolution du problème sans aller
jusqu'aux sanctions les plus dures
vladimir poutine reste ouvert au
dialogue à la diplomatie et là il l'a
redit est ce matin le vice ministre des
affaires étrangères russe a dit que la
russie ne s'apprête pas pour l'instant
un déployer des forces dans l'est de
l'ukraine mais avec ce qui s'est passé
quid des relations moscou londres est ce
que les sanctions là que vient de
dévoiler boris johnson que ça ne va pas
détériorer encore un peu plus des liens
déjà tendues entre les deux pays
oui les relations sont déjà tendues
depuis pas mal de temps et
là on est oui dans une situation assez
grave en même temps vous voyez d'un côté
il se peut que
du point de vue de londres
monsieur poutine ne fait que préparer sa
position de négociation diplomatique
en même temps d'un côté de l'autre côté
peau reste on a déjà dit qu'il croyait
qu'il y aurait une agression
donc cette première décision hier semble
lui donner raison maintenant ils
prévoient une invasion à grande échelle
de l'ukraine est-ce que les
circonstances vont lui donner encore
raison ou pas les casseurs l'essentiel
le kremlin dément depuis depuis
plusieurs plusieurs semaines
mais est-ce que downing street s'attend
à des contre-mesures russe et si oui
lesquelles
sans aucun doute sans aucun doute et
comme vous le savez quand on quand on
lance des sanctions économiques contre 1
un adversaire il y a toujours un coût
sacrificielle pour sa propre économie
et tous dépendent
de la
l'état d'esprit des britanniques est
aussi d autres breaks européen est ce
qu'ils sont prêts à aller très loin en
faisant un sacrifice économiques eux
mêmes
pour le moment ça semble l'indiquer mais
en même temps il y a toujours de la
place pour une solution diplomatique
qu'il ne faut pas l'oublier on n'en est
pas encore là le fait que boris johnson
communique beaucoup sur la crise
iranienne à il a encore dit encore
aujourd'hui que la crise sera longue par
exemple
le fait de communiquer comme ça est ce
que ce n'est pas aussi pour faire
diversion comme il est en difficulté sur
le plan intérieur avec notamment le
parti gate 1 même s'il ya d'autres
affaires
oui on l'a beaucoup dit dans les médias
en même temps il faut dire que si jamais
c'était le cas ça a bien marché parce
que le parti gate est vraiment à
l'arrière-plan maintenant tout le monde
dit que bon en fait
boris johnson et les sorties des bois il
a survécu donc
là il ne craint plus tellement cet
aspect des choses
merci jeremy steps d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes le
président du parti et conservateurs
britanniques en france